hello and welcome to this video playing
fm mike veto maybe
it could be a
flak kuba okay
i could also play some
retti catalan style
yeah i guess a check
it's been a long while since i checked
this a4 there is
b5 i guess
i think you go back voluntarily
wow isn't that good for white
why is that playable sorry but uh
i'm always amazed that moves like let
get played in a second or am i just
stupid
knight e5 and black is
really able to play that it looks
weird
so it takes takes 95 rook t1
okay maybe
that is all theory and i'm just a clown
but it looks really dangerous for like
queen e8
has to be played it's kind of the only
move
knight c3 maybe
c6 i guess so
taking a pawn on d5 is not a real option
yeah queen takes i thought
taking this tempo and now what
i'm threatening this winning the house
and that is the problem
here we go
this should be four maybe
still hanging on so
quincy or queen c2 queen c2
queen e7 bishop e3
over right yeah
no trick left
and it's it's a it's a full rook it's
not just an exchange
or something a3m
a3
well i mean full rook i mean there's
this as well
with bishop c5 and then i'm attacking
two rooks
so bishop c5
bishop c5
yeah i'm
always amazed that decisions like b5 are
made in split seconds
i mean that it's a move that looks on
first side absolutely atrocious
and if you play it i mean you have to be
really sure that it works
it might work in the sense that it's not
losing but
if you play it super risky okay knight
e5
it's totally force he has to take
and then we get this
rook t1 yeah and now this is uh
very very tough bishop d7 is uh
favored by the engine bishop d7 knight
c3 c6
yeah i mean not a happy move bishop d7
and then knight e4 i guess yeah that
that's what i would have played
there's always this idea to get the
knight to d6
which is even valid if they try to
lend additional cover to the square i
can still do that
as this sequence loses the piece
yeah when he went queen e8
knight c3 and now he cannot take he has
to probably play c6
and then after knight e4 we get a
similar
um position to the one that we just
looked at a moment ago
which is good for white but not over and
knight c3 quincy three is
just curtains
that's completely completely lost
yeah and resigns yeah i'm amazed that b5
is like played immediately because
well it's not it doesn't look like you
can do it you should probably play
some prep move rook b8 rook b8 rook d1
it's a fairly normal catalan type
position i think white should be a bit
better but nothing
too exciting okay thanks for watching